foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
she getting a divorce
[Music]
I don't know how you'll answer this long
to be going honest with you with the
Qing on [ __ ]
how is that even possible
that someone would be able to last that
freaking long
with this crazy crazy crazy lady
you know Marjorie Taylor green is who
I'm talking about she's getting a
divorce our husband filed for divorce I
guess
that's the that's the going word
um right now around and when she wants
privacy
he wants privacy
she doesn't want other women
damn privacy inside their doctor's
offices about their health decisions
but you know she definitely she
definitely wants privacy for herself
and for her family
but other folks privacy just not an
issue just not an issue at all really
when it comes to Marjorie Taylor green
again this is all on brand
for these chuckle heads
and again I I mean really honestly did
you do you think she had a I I don't
know I had no idea she was married
I did not know this
that she was married
I thought she was having some kind of
affair with the uh the sex the the
gymnasium sex guy or whatever
you know what I'm talking about
you know what I'm saying
and she has some kind of like Health
Guru or some [ __ ]
that she was having an affair with and
then and then she was really she was
touching Donald Trump's
cardboard crotch you remember this
do you think
oh my God people are gonna turn me off
and turn this [ __ ] show off do you
think
do you think that that Grandpa poopy
pants
had his diaper changed
by Marjorie Taylor who foot green do you
think
I I don't I
oh my God this is where we're at
this is where we're at
you know the craziest part about the
whole thing
is that if she wasn't such a crazy Q
Anon nut
and she wasn't such a worthless vile
piece of [ __ ] that that takes up a seat
of our Congress
no one would give a [ __ ] that she was
getting divorce no one would give a [ __ ]
I mean really I'm not surprised are you
surprised is anyone really surprised
about this that her husband is filing
for divorce
Tony you're being so mean people are
mean people are mean
people are [ __ ] mean
oh boy
the other thing that we find out
is that this J.R Majewski have you seen
this
we played the what was that yesterday
and Gabe Sanchez did a great job of
breaking down J.R majewski's
Antics and his lies
Stolen Valor is what it is
even the Republican Party are like eh
we're traitors but that Stolen Valor
thing not a good look
I mean
being on the side of Traders isn't a
good look folks
but they draw the line at Stolen Valor
especially when you do it time and time
again and then and then he comes out and
makes his claim
somehow his Services classified he pulls
the old special Master Donald Trump
trick
what the [ __ ] it's classified then why
are you running around talking about it
if it's classified
you know what classified means right J.R
Majewski
okay well that proves out to be a bunch
of [ __ ]
now he has a DUI or something
Japan or some [ __ ] I don't know
I don't really honestly a DUI
as bad as a DUI can be it's not going to
be disqualifying in most legislators
like not just Our House of
Representatives I mean Matt gatz is a
[ __ ] congressperson
I don't know that it's disqualifier
especially for the Republican Party
but he does what about ISM he's like oh
I was punished unlike Paul Pelosi
the [ __ ] does that even mean what the
[ __ ] what what does that have to do with
you having a DUI
I don't understand it I really don't get
the [ __ ]
he just put himself back in the news
again
over dumb [ __ ] folks if we can't manage
to band together and save our democracy
here [ __ ]
we're absolutely screwed now also the
other news is that Republicans on the
hill
one of them being Mitch McConnell is a
little [ __ ] freaked out
at the prospect
that the America First Nazi party the
Republican Party
that Maga Republicans will take back the
house that's right I said
the Republicans Mitch McConnell are
concerned
are you following me here you follow the
Bounce About Mitch McConnell is
concerned
that the Republicans will take back the
house
and the reason why is because Kevin
McCarthy may be the speaker
they're like ah it's not a good idea
[ __ ] that [ __ ] even they're not even
they're not fans of Kevin McCarthy at
this point
now here's the reason why they're
[ __ ] terrified if these buffoons
these these Kamikaze America First Nazis
take over the house
when you have the majority in the house
you have your hands on Appropriations
okay you basically the house determines
what to spend money on
the Executive Branch the president
writes the [ __ ] checks that the house
decides to spend the money on you got it
are you are you following people out
there don't understand how our [ __ ]
government works the House of
Representatives appropriates funds
they decide what the actual federal
government is going to spend money on
and the executive branch writes the
checks
they pay the bill in other words
that Congress the House of
Representatives writes up
and approves
now you have boneheads like oh divorcey
here
Marjorie Taylor green Matt Getz
and Lauren bobert out there going ow
we're definitely going to shut down the
government [ __ ] the government we're
gonna shut it down shut it down because
Joe Biden is is a diabolical
dementia ridden
old man who doesn't know his whole head
from a hole in the ground but it's gonna
destroy the entire world
with his diabolical strategic scheme
even though he's supposed to be mentally
incapacitated I don't I don't know which
one it is but they think shutting down
the government is going to stop Joe
Biden from being president this is not
that's not a thing
it's just going to prevent him from
writing the checks
for the money
he's not going to be able to have a
checkbook to write checks to pay the
government's bills
I wonder I wonder you know they've been
saying this [ __ ] like well the FBI can
come tomorrow
and they can they can raid the
president's house then they can raid
your house
well guess what guess what the [ __ ] will
happen if the government doesn't pay its
bills just like if you don't pay your
[ __ ] bills
they know they don't apply that logic
anywhere else even though that actually
is a logic like yeah if anyone commits
crime even the former president there
will be consequences and accountability
that that's right you're correct just
like if you shut down the government
don't pay your [ __ ] bills that'd be
[ __ ] consequences yep sure thing yeah
that's a that's a thing
that's how it works
and I don't know [ __ ] reality
but you have members of Congress who are
sitting members of Congress who are
re-running their elections who are
likely going to win in these crazy Q
Anon areas
that their whole message is to shut down
the government
that's what they're going to do they're
going to shut it down we're going to
keep it shut down until Donald Trump is
crowned king or whatever the [ __ ]
they're thinking I don't know
Mitch McConnell and the Republicans
understand what's going to happen
they know they know what will happen
if they do that it will tank the economy
absolutely tank the economy
it could have worldwide effects on
financial markets
it it could collapse
some [ __ ] governments around the
world because they rely on our markets
staying open
and our credit rating for our treasury
bills you [ __ ] idiots
like we have treasury bills with credit
ratings that people buy from us
and that's how we flood money into the
system sometimes
and these people are just gonna ah [ __ ]
it we don't need we don't need credit
[ __ ] would we just have bad credit all
over the world [ __ ] it
they're not thinking rationally here
these people think there's [ __ ] space
lasers for crying out loud
they think the reason why we have
forest fires in California is because
you don't rake leaves
God knows God knows what you could even
drum up with these dummies in their
brains
about what's happening in Florida over
the last 24 hours
and I said yesterday Ron DeSantis is
gonna [ __ ] this up and here's why folks
he [ __ ] it up before he even started
him and Marco Rubio both
they did the thing that Republicans
always do
when it comes to other areas of the
country that isn't them they vote
against this [ __ ] relief
for constituents for Americans for
people who are here who work here who
live here
who want safety even from storms
and flooding which the flooding down the
floor is absolutely crazy and there's
um I don't know that we even have an
official death count yet
and I'm I I've never lived in Florida
I've lived in areas that have potential
to flood but not potential for
hurricanes tornadoes uh flood flooding
and
um I I guess you just get used to these
types of storms
I don't fully grasp why Floridians don't
take some of these storms seriously but
at the same time I understand if you
live in that area for a long time you're
very used to these storms you think you
can ride them out
the flooding on this one is absolutely
insane
it's insane
and all the people in Florida should
remain safe
it's just a shame that they have a
derelict governor and he's derelict and
from the from before he even started
folks
the fact that Ron DeSantis is a
republican Congressman would vote
against aid for Hurricane Sandy should
have been disqualifying him for being
Governor think about this think about it
the governor is the one who takes the
federal funds during a national disaster
and this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and we know Florida is gonna have
natural disasters it's not it's it's a
state
that is absolutely in the path of
hurricanes
it's not if we're if Florida's gonna
have a problem with hurricanes it's when
which year will it be worse than others
this [ __ ] voted against
funding for Hurricane Sandy because [ __ ]
them people and [ __ ] people Coastal
Elites
[ __ ] gonna be running around to
stay passing out money
and he's going to be begging for money
and Joe Biden and the and the the the
federal government and the
administration and FEMA are going to
Spring and that they sprung an action
before it even happened
but if you think if you think for a
second that Ron DeSantis
is going to do what is best for
Floridians you do not know Ron DeSantis
you don't know him you just don't know
him and unfortunately this is
unfortunate that Florida now has to deal
with this storm in a time where he is
the [ __ ] governor
he does not he does not have any
Humanity decency or empathy at all
he's a piece of [ __ ] vile [ __ ] Ron
desantises and frankly Rhonda Santos can
go [ __ ] himself
oh Tony Jesus Christ he's trying to deal
with yeah that's the problem is we have
Ron DeSantis trying to deal with this
natural disaster that's the [ __ ]
problem
these elections that you go to and you
participate in are so [ __ ] important
and it ain't got nothing to do about
[ __ ] books Republicans it ain't got
nothing to do about mandates Mass
mandates q and honors it ain't got
nothing to do with that [ __ ] it has to
do with real life real [ __ ] governing
[ __ ]
real policy type stuff not [ __ ] what
you weirdos wanna [ __ ]
concentrate about children's genitalia
and their [ __ ] gender and you people
are [ __ ] weird you're [ __ ] weird
you're just [ __ ] weird it's crazy
when you have hundreds of deaths
thousands of people who need to be
rescued in the State of Florida now
because of this storm which again
in Florida it's not if they're going to
get hurricanes it's when and how bad it
will be
and they elected the people of Florida
elected a governor who voted against
National disaster funds as a as a
republican Congressman because he didn't
like the people it was going to
you don't think you don't think when
this money this Federal money gets put
in the hands of Ron DeSantis that he's
gonna pick and choose who gets this
money
get the [ __ ] out of here there is no
evidence anywhere that you can point to
that says he's going to do anything
otherwise
and he's definitely definitely not going
to
make sure that it's done properly from
the federal level because he doesn't
want Joe Biden to get credit
because he's a traitor
he doesn't like America
he's not a patriot he's a fascist he
doesn't like our democracy he doesn't
like the people in his state
he wants to ostracize them
Jesus Christ he he would love he would
love to lock up lgbtq people in camps
doubt me doubt me I'm giving [ __ ] you
say whatever you want
[ __ ] shipping shipping refugees
seeking legal asylum in this country
from a communist regime in Venezuela
like their pieces of meats as a
political stunt to a place that doesn't
even have the resources to handle them
so much so that those people spring in
action there to get into places where
they do have resources
and Ronda santis Rhonda Santos is the
guy anyone once in charge of [ __ ]
anything especially
especially one of the the largest
hurricane recovers we've seen in a long
time because of all the flooding
and apparently they're supposed to get
dead they they've knocked this
um stormed down a bit but apparently
they're still supposed to get 30 inches
of rain I think I don't know if they
change forecast now hopefully it dies
off as it moves
and there's just there's just less
damage and less death
that's all we can hope for
but you think Ron DeSantis gives two
shits he's wanting to score political
points here
he doesn't care about being a [ __ ]
leader Jesus Christ he wasted 12 million
dollars 12 million dollars on a
political stunt to dehumanize
again refugees seeking a legal Asylum
here from a communist regime in
Venezuela
he spent 12 million dollars 240 000 a
piece
to go coerce them into a plane in a
different state and then ship them on
that plane to his State and then ship
them to Martha's Vineyard two hundred
and forty thousand dollars a piece and
it's likely that there were crimes
committed
and that's the guy you want in charge of
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding me
I I don't know I don't know exactly
every single lawn in the State of
Florida for voting
but by God if you are in an area where
it's not devastated by the storm and you
can early vote [ __ ] I'd be going to Mark
and Charlie Crist right now Jesus Christ
you're telling me you want to keep the
guy who told the people of Hurricane
Sandy to go [ __ ] themselves as a
congressman that's the guy you want in
charge of cleaning up This Disaster as
governor in Florida again that should
have been the number one disqualifier
for Rhonda santis even becoming a
candidate on the Republican ticket
for governor when the governor is the
one who oversees the disaster relief in
the in the Disaster Cleanup after
hurricanes
that should have been number one on the
list nope can't be Governor sorry [ __ ]
you're a dumb [ __ ] you have no no
[ __ ] compassion when it comes to
natural disasters it's clear with your
vote it's clear
he's a piece of [ __ ]
he's a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] and don't
give me this well he's the governor and
he's got a lot he's dealing I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't care if he's got a lot to
deal with right now there's a shitload
of Floridians that have a lot Mayors
fire departments Rescue Services
utility services that got a lot to deal
with
and it would be helpful if it wasn't
some vile gross piece of [ __ ] in charge
of trying to coordinate
this cleanup and these rescues
in this recovery that is going to take
Florida months and months and months to
get over
and again I I I I hope that all
Floridians stay safe
if you can hear me out there I know MJ
one of our moderators uh we love you MJ
here I know people love you in the chat
and and I didn't catch if you were here
today in the chat let me take a look
here now everyone Give Love Yes MJ is
here everyone give love to MJ she's down
in Florida she's safe
I was hoping she would remain safe and
her family would remain safe and anyone
else who's in the chat every single day
from Florida I want you to stay safe too
and I wish safety to Ron DeSantis for
crying out loud and his family
but you think he's gonna do that for
others no he's not
he's never given proof of that at all
never
and then you go to Marco Rubio same [ __ ]
where is Marco by the way where is that
[ __ ] anybody see him lately
last time we seen him he was skating
questions on a National Abortion ban
because he's all in for taking away
people's Liberty
these are who these people are
and you want these stupid [ __ ]
in charge
of something when when a a natural
disaster like hurricane Ian happens in
the State of Florida that's what you
want get the [ __ ] out of here you people
are dumb if you want someone like Ron
DeSantis or Marco Rubio in charge of
anything even working their way out of a
wet paper sack you are a dumb
[ __ ] you are a stupid piece of
[ __ ] and you're just as racist just as
fascist and you deserve everything
that's coming to them
which is rejection
because I believe that is the one thing
we have left here is to pile mountains
just [ __ ] mountains of votes on top
of these son of a [ __ ]
because you can guarantee that Ron
DeSantis is gonna [ __ ] this up
he is going to [ __ ] this up big time
and it's Gonna Hurt Floridians his
constituents and that's his intention
folks
his intention when he [ __ ] this up when
we go what the [ __ ] why the [ __ ] would
he do that it's because he's trying to
hurt folks
because he's a vile piece of [ __ ]
he does it intentionally he spent 12
million [ __ ] dollars 12 million
[ __ ] dollars of Floridians money to
hurt
refugees seeking Asylum from a communist
regime
he intentionally hurt them
dehumanize them
you don't think he'll do the same thing
did for Floridians with this recovery
from Hurricane in you goddamn right he's
going to
so if you if you if you still can hear
me in Florida and I know that there's
places that just don't have power
there's almost three million people I
think that are out of power
stay safe in Florida please please stay
safe
we're thinking of you you are our fellow
Americans regardless of your citizenship
status
regardless of your sexuality
doesn't matter you are Americans you are
here
we love you
even people flying Rhonda Santa's Flags
and [ __ ] Joe Biden Flags you're you're
here
you deserve the same dignity as everyone
else through this storm
but your governor
the one that you elected is not capable
is not ready
to make sure
that he's a leader
folks
it's Thursday
do you know what happens here on the
Tony Michaels podcast on Thursday
we send out a poll you get to vote here
on the Tony Michaels podcast for
bonehead of the week
so don't forget to go over to Twitter
and follow us at Tony Michaels pod
follow me and Gabe at Tony Michaels the
Tony Michaels and that I am Gabe Sanchez
there on Twitter you can vote there you
can also vote on YouTube so don't forget
to subscribe over here we're almost at
10 grand 10
000 Subs here holy [ __ ] on YouTube so do
us a favor if you're on Facebook twitch
Twitter our viewing on YouTube watching
right now please hit that subscribe
button come over and subscribe we are so
close we're less than a hundred I think
when we came on air
uh from from from 10 000 which is a huge
milestone and I again I appreciate every
single one of you being here every
single day chatting uh coming along for
the conversation politicizing the
ever-loving [ __ ] so we can win our
democracy and make sure the
pro-democracy party and the
pro-democracy policy makers are in place
for when [ __ ] like hurricane Ian happens
so they're not voting against it you're
not going to find one [ __ ] Democrat
not [ __ ] one Democrat is gonna vote
against [ __ ] Aid to Florida
for Hurricane Ian matter of fact there's
probably going to be Democrat members of
the house and the Senate that aren't
even representing Florida that will help
with efforts
to get even more relief not just Federal
money but charity money
down to Florida because that's what
compassionate decent people do
this is what they do
and when your pro-democracy you're
typically
decent compassionate you have empathy
the thing that happens with democracy
when you're a fascist you're not you can
count on it
so make sure you follow us because we
have bone of the week because I'm sure
I'm sure some of these
boneheads are gonna end up on the list
by tomorrow by tomorrow Rhonda Santos is
going to do some dumb [ __ ] I'm sure so
if he's not on the running as a
contestant right now you damn sure
better bet he's going to be dishonorable
mention her Outback I'm sure we'll see
what Gabe Sanchez does with this with
this bonehead Elite pole so don't forget
to go subscribe to subscribe to the
YouTube channel
and follow us on Twitter but also
download every single episode Monday
through Friday
we come live noon Eastern
every single day but we download every
single episode as soon as we're done
well sometimes it takes me a little bit
to edit it sometimes but we try to get
it uploaded as soon as possible on Apple
Spotify Google your favorite directory
and while you're there downloading
today's episode later on this afternoon
make sure you subscribe on your favorite
directory and give us a give us a review
there don't forget to follow us on
Facebook either at the Tony Michaels we
have our own Facebook page you guys have
been liking going over there there's
been a lot of people coming over to
Facebook
on on our page so if you're like on the
mind of such Facebook page go on our
page follow our page we broadcast over
there too I post all kinds of crazy
memes over there if you want to spread
those around the books of face and also
follow us on Twitch if you like that
platform a lot of people like to chat
and twitch
we're trying to be everywhere folks
anywhere and everywhere we do we want to
get the word out we want you guys to
watch this show no matter where you were
at
we don't mind where you're at because we
run on your support
we run on your support rather it's
watches likes listens subscribes follows
retweets
comments in the Instagrams
are here on YouTube we run on your
support and if you'd like to give us
monetary support we appreciate that too
you can tip us at tonymichaels dot live
slash tip Tony Michaels dot live slash
tip you can give a one-time dip you see
it there on the screen or you can set it
up monthly that way you gotta you gotta
remember it and you can do five dollars
ten dollar whatever you want
you can do whatever amount you want one
time tip or monthly tip we run on your
support and we appreciate every single
last bit of it
we also want to offer is support you can
go to the Tony michaels.com
store.dtonymichaels.com and you can get
your dark brand and Merch this stuff is
flying off the shelves everyone loves
the dark Brandon merch but I know this
is going to get popular
the Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself
everyone's been ordering these shirts
they've been getting them and posting
pictures online of their Rhonda Santos
can go [ __ ] himself shirt
it's going to be a popular one so go to
store.dtonymichaels.com
store.the tonymichaels.com
and get your great exclusive the Tony
Michaels podcast designs and thank you
for all your support truly we love
having you guys here we can't believe
we've reached 10 000 and we've grown so
fast just in the last six months uh I
know the majority is Midas Mighty and we
love having the mightiest Mighty here
but we know there's other folks here
like our haters
and we love our haters our hate watchers
good morning to you all
it's a great morning for you to be here
on the Tony Michaels podcast
we we like our hate Watchers why
wouldn't we why wouldn't we
uh everyone we're gonna do this shitless
Roundup as soon as we get back from the
break I'm sure Gabe Sanchez will be
joining us everyone stick around don't
go anywhere shitless Roundup right after
this break we'll see you right on the
other side
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
years Bob dear Bob I'm fixing to send
you some more of them Doritos you like
the red bag not the lived love and blue
one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[ __ ] um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thanks for sticking around through the
break
[Music]
Trucker's Convoy I like that one that's
a good one that's a great well that's a
great that's a great little clip we love
the Trekkers Convoy here
I always forget about that one I always
forget about it I don't know I forget
about it
is everyone staying safe this morning
apparently it's National Coffee Day I've
had my limit to Coffee I think for today
I'm just I'm running on water now but I
did have several coffee it's supposed to
be is it in that what they said National
Coffee Day let's see National Coffee Day
is today yeah National Coffee Day that's
what it is and we have some news from
North Korea apparently uh the vice
president and the Korean South Korean
president uh condemned North Korea's
intensifying nuclear rhetoric and
weapons test
day after the isolated country conducted
the latest in the series of missile
tests so North Korea is uh conducting
some missile tests and the vice
president Kamala Harris and the South
Korean president condemn those actions
lizzo lizzo's still trending over this
Crystal flute have you seen this
I guess she came out on stage it's uh
John excuse me James Madison's Crystal
flute it's on a Library of Congress had
it so she came out on stage at blade
it's really [ __ ] cool
now this this flute thing but uh so
lizzo lizzo's still on the news and the
reason why is because all these right
Wingers are [ __ ] pissed they're
[ __ ] pissed
that lizzo played this flute
I don't know they're they're really mad
that she touched James Madison's flute
Crystal flute it really is kind of
stupid I mean the video is cool but yeah
the response from these right Wingers
why are they so butthurt about lizzo
I mean it's it's obvious that like
people like Matt Walsh are really upset
that lizzo is heavy
but what the [ __ ] does that have to do
with him why is he so mad
that lizzo not only is a big girl but
she Embraces it matter of fact she's
very confident about it why in the [ __ ]
is he so pissed off about this
these people are obsessed with other
people's bodies have you noticed that
this is [ __ ] weird stuff weird [ __ ]
when these conservatives are absolutely
obsessed with other people's clothing
with their [ __ ] genitalia with their
body type with how much weight they want
to carry this is and how confident they
are about it this is really [ __ ]
stupid stuff
but of course that's where they go
because they can't make a good argument
against lizzo as an artist no [ __ ]
way not even close couldn't make that
argument wouldn't work but they can be
like oh she fat
and she's proud of it and that pisses me
off I don't I don't understand it I I
mean I I do they're white racist
they're white male racist and she's
black woman I get it I get it she's a
black woman they're racist so they they
point to her weight because boy they
they couldn't say anything else and if
they said something about her skin color
boy they really be in trouble they'd be
canceled you'll cancel me [ __ ] idiots
uh Samuel Leto I guess is in the news as
well
Justice Samuel Alito and that piece of
[ __ ] I guess he's really upset that
people are critiquing the Supreme Court
the conservative majority how dare you
question our legitimacy what are you
talking about
we could question anything we [ __ ]
want [ __ ]
you're taking away rights from Americans
we definitely can question your
legitimacy
at least at a minimum your motive
for [ __ ] taking away people's rights
you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] him
Alito no [ __ ] out of here with this guy
um cyber truck is trending now oh Elon
Musk you know we haven't heard a lot of
Elon Musk news since he uh he couldn't
get he couldn't get the deal with
Twitter done he just couldn't finish
he just couldn't finish the deal uh so
now he's now he's talking about his uh
cyber truck
um I guess it's gonna be waterproof
enough to be a boat so is it a cyber
truck or a cyber boat Gabe Sanchez which
is this thing this this Elon Mustang
have you seen this yeah I I heard that
he was gonna make it so that you could
go through like some light uh at least
light water light light water like so
not like he was able to endure so like a
mud puddle okay yeah pretty much oh what
it sounds like is like some
uh some type of version of like a duck
boat you know what those are right yeah
yeah right these are the ones that
capsize and kill dozens of people is
that what you're talking about yeah yeah
right and then you would go to like
Wisconsin Dells and be like Oh I'm going
to like the Ducks yeah well see they got
them in Branson now the ones in Branson
um and I we we've actually rode them
before before
we discovered the horrifying fact that
the cover on them is the thing that
actually kills people because the boat
as original design doesn't have this big
huge like shaded cover because they
weren't really made for like tourist
things they were made for military use
right but like when it capsizes the the
the the cover traps the human beings in
the boat when it when it goes under the
water which is not a humans just don't
do well underwater very long so do you
think do you think this Elon Musk cyber
boat or cyber truck whatever the hell
it's supposed to be do you think it'll
show up at these um these Trump Boat
Parade things and it they'll sink I'm
just I mean they all kind of sink I'm
just saying I don't know here's what I
do think will happen is there will be
people who decide that they can go test
this out right and they'll go driving in
water like it's like one of those things
where it's like oh how long can you keep
your phone underwater before actual
damage happens to it you know right
there are gonna be people who drive this
thing intentionally like oh yeah forget
man and some people are going to be fine
and other people are gonna not be able
to make it out you know so well there's
going to be a lot of viral videos with
these things if he ever get some release
you know it really is kind of weird
though that he's he's still in this
weird sort of way trying to
placate to this group that absolutely
hates
absolutely hates who Elon Musk is and
he's he's still playing to this crypto
bro type trumped up
I just I I never really understood what
they why they liked him so much because
it's like you know he is everything that
you say you hate I mean Jesus I mean it
just it's weird it's weird to me but
you know Elon I mean I don't know if you
also if you mentioned it yet or not but
it was the uh the the details the more
details have come out about the whole
like Twitter bot allegations oh really
what what what's the news on that
because we've been distracted from
something so maybe we should talk about
Elon for a few minutes here before we
get to the [ __ ] let's ramble if I
remember correctly that I think this
came out yesterday uh the Tesla uh so
Elon was like Hey There are these Bots
and I shouldn't have to pay the 44
billion because you guys lied about it
right
uh but it turns out that that is not the
case let me see if I can find the
article specifically
um
it was it was a I think it was from
from so you're saying so what you're
saying is that Elon lied
oh well yeah well not only that oh man
I'm trying to find this right now Under
Pressure uh but basically there was like
a it was a data analyst or a data
scientist at his company that looked at
and was like nah I'm not finding any of
this like the stuff that you claim and
I'm the one who is an expert in this
field
um
so let me see if I can
it's really um you know it comes on the
heels of this uh announcing this cyber
truck is going to be a boat too and
again I I think he's trying I mean it
feels like to me he's trying to appeal
he's like no it's a truck that you can
hang your huh I mean is he trying to
appeal like trying to make himself like
oh look I've got a solution for all
those hurricanes that come through oh
[ __ ] I I mean that I mean I I guess I
could be possible close where I would
look at him where he's calling it a boat
yeah like I feel like he's like oh look
if you're trying to get out of these
hurricane conditions in Florida then you
you'll need a cyber truck it just feels
like the timing is too close to each
other that he wouldn't try to
like uh capitalize on the event like
have you seen this cyber truck have you
seen this thing I've seen the original
one where he threw the bowling ball at
it and then it broke the uh broke the
window I I'm not seeing that video but
this is put it on stage they threw like
I threw a weight or a bowling ball at it
and it broke the windows like oh looks
like we still got to work on some stuff
wait wait wait so he didn't he didn't
test that out before he tried it you
know live on I don't know if I tested it
out uh this thing is [ __ ] ugly by the
way it's ugly as Sin and really honestly
maybe maybe he's like it doesn't even
look like a truck it looks more like a
boat so we're just gonna call it a boat
I don't know what the [ __ ] he's thinking
I'm gonna turn the sound off here
because I don't know what the sound is
and I want to get dinged on copyright
but here's the um Here's the the the it
it this looks like
I mean it kind of looks cool it doesn't
look really look like a truck to me
right but it just it's kind of
futuristic which you know I guess isn't
surprising but this is the this is the
truck here
um you're seeing on screen
and I guess again because it looks like
a boat I mean the ass end of it if you
look at the ass end of it I don't know
if you've been around a lot of boats but
I mean that looks like a [ __ ] boat it
looks like a damn outboard motor is
supposed to be mounted to the back of
that son of a [ __ ]
like you're gonna go fishing out of this
[ __ ] I mean that's when I see
the back of this thing I'm like is that
a boat with wheels or is that boat on a
trailer what the hell is that I mean it
looks like a boat you know elon's not
the the best when it comes to uh yeah
well you know it happens it happens so I
guess I guess we'll dig a little more on
the Elon thing sorry but I just spoke it
was a it was a metal ball they it was a
metal ball I thought for whatever reason
it was a bowling ball just for the
weight and the Damage that it did but
here is um
here is the actual like little video I
think is a gif and this is what
this is what they tested on it at the
when they announced the Cyber truck
right they're like we're gonna have the
Cyber truck and it's got all these
things and you can do
oh whoops that's the wrong one oops
sorry that's the this is this is the
first this is the first uh Tesla cyber
truck model sorry about that that's a
different one so it's important uh why
why this video is shown right because
Elon Musk was like oh it can survive or
withstand a nine millimeter and it says
it in the Tweet here too
but he was bragging about it he's like
Oh look The the car is designed or the
truck is designed to survive this type
of
uh now this isn't actually Elon throwing
this because I don't know the Elon could
throw this thing that hard no no no no
tweet
yeah so there he's throwing it and it
obviously it breaks the window yeah
breaks the window now that's just a
metal ball right right looks like it
looks like a a big ball bearing or
something yeah yeah I'm not sure if you
look at the tweet
you know and I think this is important
to point out is that it's based on the
claim that it's literally bulletproof to
a nine millimeter handgun literally is
the word yeah literally and they test
that not theoretically right not like it
should be like we actually designed it
that's what literally means right in
this instance like we designed it one of
those it's one of those things where
somebody makes a claim they show the
product obviously you know you would
hope that if you're gonna make the claim
and then you're gonna show that the
product that it matches up with those
claims obviously this is an early or you
know a somewhat finished prototype of
what they had but it you know if you're
gonna say it you can't
you can't test it you might want to back
it up right you might want to back it up
so well it's just you know you know I
I'm never going to
um not do some Elon bashing here on the
Tony Michaels podcast but I want to get
to the shitless Roundup here because we
got a lot of news I want to talk about
Florida
um and some of the updates because it's
gonna we're gonna get a lot of news uh
updates very quickly as this goes on and
as they assess the damage in Florida
hopefully they can get power and again
anyone in Florida be safe
um we're our hearts are with you and
really honestly
um if you can
just just stay safe don't try to do
anything more than staying safe at this
moment because I think that's most
important in Florida right now is to not
try to do things that are going to make
you unsafe but we have this Genie Thomas
Genie Thomas uh came in today now so
there's some footage of that that I want
to break down
um and also I Know Dan Quay sales
um trending in I'm not sure why um but
Hurricane Sandy is trending and I think
that's because of uh Ron DeSantis is a
piece of [ __ ] and he voted against Sandy
um funding so we're going to talk about
that a little more I talked about the
beginning of the hour but
I want to talk about that more um so
let's do this and I want to show
everybody this lizzo video of her
playing James Madison's Crystal flute
the video is cool the right wing
response is on brand oh pissed oh it's
on brand so let's do this let's let's
surf the Tweety tweets and the trendy
Trends everyone get ready for the
shitless Roundup start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
up where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and journey trends
Gabe Matt Walsh is just really upset
that lizzo is confident enough in her
body to walk around on stage in a thong
he's just really upset he is he is so
upset that she would show her body parts
that he's obsessed with on stage her own
body well right yeah her own body her
body her choice well you know these
things these things have a way of being
hypocritical we showed that yesterday
with the video we we watched in the very
end now here is lizzo on stage
um she's gonna be grabbing a crystal
flute apparently as James Madison's
flute it is from the Smithsonian is that
right is that do I have that right
that's where it was actually displayed
and it's on loan well I know she's in DC
which isn't even great artist too right
um but she's gonna play this flute
Library Congress is where it's is where
it's held it is apparently a Christmas
she even makes a joke about a bean
Crystal where I've been trying to play
it but she does a wonderful job playing
it from 1813. 1813. so this thing's a
couple years old right yes it's pretty
new yeah all right it is it's almost as
new as a cyber truck let's let's watch
lizzo play the crystal flute and let's
see what the right wing is so offended
about I'm sure there's just a lot to be
offended about
okay she grabs the flute
which one would do to play the flute
the crowd is excited she has the flute
I don't see anything controversial yet
he said something into the microphone
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe they're offended at the wine glass
joke I'm not real sure
foreign
[Applause]
what are you surmising over there why
they're so offended I think I know why
Tony what's what is it what is that it's
because uh an empowered black woman
is in DC in front of thousands of people
yeah playing on something that only a
white oh man I see you could play
I'm very upset very upset very triggered
that that this is one the first time
they've ever seen this thing and two the
closest they'll ever be to actually
seeing it since it's you know owned and
and and protected by the Library of
Congress the same people well yeah
anyway uh that is why that is why
they're upset it's because she's a black
woman playing a white man's flute
exactly
well you know this is kind of funny
because it feels like to me they are
upset because they're so good at playing
it too right well that does piss him off
big time yeah because they really I mean
what they're really hoping for was she
would not be confident in the outfit
that she was wearing because lizzo is
very confident with her body type she
has no problem being confident about her
body but some people had that body type
and they aren't confident and that's
fine too
but they're very upset that she's a
black woman who's confident with her
body type she's obviously confident
about it and they really were hoping she
would fall on her face here playing this
flute and she absolutely did not and the
crowd responded correctly when she
whistled out that's what I'd call it I
don't know you flew that you whistle I
don't know what the it sounds like I'm
not a floutist so is that what it's is
that what it's called flowers yeah it's
not a flutist no no no no I'm flutist
and be a flutist I don't know it'd be a
blue just like it salsa yeah fun fact
about flutes
anyone who watched Anchorman the first
one right there's the jazz flute scene
where he's like in the club and he's
like and he's playing all over the place
the guy who actually played that song
and made that music uh was as an alumni
of my high school oh okay he's he's a
flutist okay yeah he's a flutist okay so
um so they're really pissed off about
lizzo and I I actually think the reason
why they're really pissed off here to be
quite honest is that she showed her ass
cheeks
thrisson and that and she's a black
woman and she she showed her ass cheeks
while she was playing James Madison's
flute and that in 2022 is just
unacceptable that would happen play that
flute is a a white old man who owns
property and by property I mean people
and that is why people like uh
Matt Walsh are upset and so true I want
to be the one who plays the flute you
know I'm going into Ben Shapiro now but
uh it's actually an actual actually
um a real man a real a real man who
protects women uh is a soldier and he
goes on the battlefield and he plays
that flute so well so well he he just
tucks it and just deep throats that
flute
um
Ben Shapiro and Matt Walsh are cut from
the same cloth right right absolutely
Kirk and all those other [ __ ] [ __ ]
they all are very butt hurt about the
fact that a woman who is
who feels comfortable in her own body to
do with her own body make her own
choices is Talent enough to play a flute
a crystal flute that no one has probably
touched since well James Madison died
is playing this [ __ ] so well and
didn't even do that she just played a
few notes she's played a few notes and
they were so upset
so upset
it is upsetting it is upsetting It's
upsetting that lizzo has so much talent
so much talent in those in this and just
in the fingers in those few notes that
she played she has so much talent right
I mean just astronomical more amounts of
talent than Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro and
Charlie Kirk had ever dream of having
yeah it is it is it is infuriating and
again they're upset that probably they
never even knew this thing existed and
now to the fact that it's getting
introduced to them is played by a black
woman oh that's really exciting to them
they will never be able to get within
viewing range of that thing right and
lizzo got to touch it and not only touch
it but play it it really pisses him off
it really pisses him off when what
actually should piss them off is this
video here here's another video of a
woman in DC okay
um this is the one that should piss them
off it's almost like they want to be
distracted by the lizzo video yeah uh
because and that's what they want us to
do but that's why I'm following up the
lizzo video because you're paying
attention with this video because this
is the actual video that you should be
[ __ ] outraged about in DC watch the
smug [ __ ] look on Genie Thomas's face
when she walks into the January 6th
select committee to to testify
we'll play it we'll talk I'll play the
video here
Miss Thomas why do you feel like you
need to speak to the committee to clear
your name
in here did you speak with your husband
if your beliefs of the election being
stolen
thank you for your question I look
forward to answering the members
okay my my my concern with this is the
way is the way in which she responds
where she's like so soft-spoken and she
says thank you so much thank you so much
for asking that question
um you know it's what it's it's you know
you know what you're reminded of of uh
she reminds me of Kathy Bates From
Misery who's like that type of
I don't know there's something about
about her whether it's she looks kind of
similar in her appearance or the way
that she's kind of trying to place off
spoken very sweet but actually she's
this [ __ ] person that behind the
scenes is is [ __ ] crazy but I look I
I look at this and the way that she's
like oh thank you so much like so
soft-spoken and trying to be so polite
even though she was someone who tried to
[ __ ] overthrow the government and her
husband is a sitting Justice on the
Supreme Court and she was texting the
chief of staff to the president United
States right this is not this is not
like she was typing this out on a
Facebook group which she probably was
but but she wasn't just typing this out
on a Facebook group for other people to
go oh this crazy [ __ ] has got some good
stuff to say no she was texting
the white house chief of staff
and she was texting him Q Anon
conspiracy theories which is only
bleeding into the brain of Grandpa
Poopypants and because it was coming
from Jeannie Thomas he saw legitimacy in
it right and Alito this morning is
pissed off that we're wondering why
we're questioning the [ __ ] the the
absolute [ __ ] legitimacy of our court
get the [ __ ] out of here Alito it's not
even and it's not even like she sent one
text message or two to be like hey you
up question mark wine glass no what she
texted was like you want to overthrow
the government okay cool here's 29 text
messages between Jenny Thomas and
uh uh Mark Meadows to talk about how we
can't we can't let Biden be president we
need to anoint
president Trump he needs to be the real
leader we need to stand firm with the
great president you and here's it here's
one help this great president stand for
Mark you are the leader with him who is
standing for America's constitutional
governments at the precipice the
majority knows Biden in the left is
attempting the greatest Heist of our
history and that's just one message
which by the way is so grammatically
[ __ ] up and and wrong
it reminds me of Trump's like run-on
sentences when he makes a you know his
little Trump announcement now not only
did she text though not only did she
text though she organized she organized
and and received funding to bus people
to the Insurrection itself like so to
think that the January 6th select
committee is just gonna Focus just on
the text messages and her Q Anon
conspiracy theories is ridiculous
they're gonna try to get to the bottom
of it and I actually believe that
they're gonna talk now apparently this
is not under oath
um somehow they negotiated the deal
where it's not under oath but here's the
thing the the Department of Justice is
going to get every single piece of this
testimony whether it's under oath or not
yeah um they're going to get this
testimony and anything there's no reason
there's I mean if she lies then you know
right I mean I know she won't be
punished well she won't be punished she
won't be punished perjury for there but
it doesn't matter they're still going to
use what she says they're still going to
use it in an investigation education for
if she's criminally liable here for any
kind of obstruction of justice or
seditious conspiracy which it's kind of
funny that Jeannie Thomas is walking
into the January 6th select committee to
try to clear her name as a reporter
there said which that's what she's
trying to do right they're trying
they're all trying to make it to where
they don't have criminal ability to go
to prison for Trump that's what they're
trying to do and Jamie Thomas is one of
them and we also can't forget the fact
that she tried to influence the electors
of uh Arizona and Wisconsin right or the
lawmakers of those places by emailing
them and not just a few of them not just
a few of them dozens of them so she's
now part of the fake electors scheme
which is has a grand jury in DC convened
to investigate that for charges this is
all this is all um Coming uh into Focus
here and you know we were supposed to
have the uh the season two premiere of
treason Hunters this week yesterday and
that hearing got postponed apparently
the news is Benny Thompson the uh the uh
chair says that we probably will not see
a hearing next week but they expect to
have it scheduled sometime soon now
rather that means before the weekend or
directly after it but it doesn't seem
that we're going to have this hearing
scheduled next week it probably is going
to be that week after
um that's what the chair has said of the
January 6th select committee but we were
supposed to have that this week but the
trial of Stuart Rhodes
the founder of The Oath Keepers he
started with seditious conspiracy nope
that's not delayed that trial is ongoing
as we speak and I believe that Ed is
going to be very damaging to people like
I don't know Roger Stone Mike Flynn
possibly Alex Jones
um because they were communicating about
that day and not only seeking
communication with those folks they were
seeking communication with the White
House with the white house if we watched
the tape and the underground parking
garage of Enrique tario who is also
charged with seditious conspiracy
coordinating with Stuart Rhodes who is
on trial this week with the the uh the
lady from the Latinos from Trump and she
had contact with the White House five
times prior right to that meeting Bianca
Garcia yes that's it that's it that's
her name I don't know like the list of
Traders is getting so long but it is
telling that she's one of the key people
within the monster of that graph and the
monster when I say the monster I'm
talking about the graph the wriggleman
that showed all the different vectors of
communication that were happening
between these groups and there were six
main uh vectors that happened or that
that they were there and these people
you know some of which that were in the
garage planning on January 5th before
the January 16th erection were some of
those people and it makes you very
concerned especially with how many
people were in contact directly with the
White House whether
you know through
um
uh a a a phone line or through an actual
contact or whatever but it's very weird
that these people
are the ones trying to get Communication
in directly through some sort of proxy
or directly through the White House well
and the other thing I think that the
story and the data and we talked a lot
about data the other day is that and how
it works and you know how they can
collect it and it's not just one point
where the data is stored there's several
points where the data can be stored
where they can recover this data but the
one piece of data that I think no one's
still talking about is all the burner
phones did they get that data did they
capture the burner phone data I think
that's probably going to be a really
important question and I really think
that some of this communication that
they had is going to be is gonna show up
in the Stuart Rhodes trial and it's not
going to be good for Republicans
um you know I got some Waffle Houses
trending yeah I don't mean to switch
nothing ever good happens I don't mean
to switch gears here but it's kind of
making me hungry do you like Waffle
House do you like Waffle House uh I
can't recall the last time I went to a
waffle house maybe when I was on a road
trip when I lived in the midwest right
there's a lot of them like along
interstates out but I can't honestly
remember the last time that I
actually went to one if I had to guess
it was like over 10 years ago right well
they're they're uh they're a great late
night stop if you need one because
they're always open but apparently
Waffle House shut down 21 of its
restaurants in Florida ahead of the
hurricane Philip Lewis writes
um landfall in what is being seen as a
testament to the category four storms
forecast strengthen severity I think
Philip is trying to say if Waffle House
was like Hey get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah then that's something like you know
they would be serving waffles and
pancakes with three feet of water in
that thing probably so I mean also
whenever you hear Waffle House there's
always like some fight or some crazy
thing that happened and you're like oh
of course it was at a waffle house right
How would how would it not happen there
crazy [ __ ] happens at Waffle Houses have
you seen some of these Waffle House
videos it's not always like bad stuff
too sometimes it's crazy good stuff
you're like what the [ __ ] that happened
I would say no Waffle House is
definitely a mixing pot of like right
absolutely our Melting Pot of like
different people that are crossing
through because obviously you you find a
lot of them at like an oasis or
somewhere so you got people that are
coming through and some things that are
good and some things that are not good
but whenever his Waffle House it's never
it's never just like in the middle like
there's not there's like not benign it's
always like oh that's [ __ ] crazy
right and it just depends on which end
of the spectrum you're on right
um because it's it's typically good or
it's typically bad but again never like
in the middle like oh yeah I went to
Waffle House and nothing happened it's
like I went to Waffle House and this
[ __ ] went down
why is Daniel Dan Quayle why is Dan
Quayle trending is this because Kamala
Harris
is talking about the Republic of North
Korea I guess they're I guess they're
doing more missile tests maybe and so
they
um you know they've got Kamala Harris
the vice president United States giving
statements and of course the right wing
is freaking out
about the vice president
giving statements here
I don't know why I I'm not sure why but
the Dan Quayle is trending I thought it
might have been that Mike Pence called
Dan Quayle again to see if he should go
testify in front of the January 6th
select committee all right should I do
that Dan is that a thing I should yes
that is the thing you should do Mike you
should go testify in front of the
January 6th select committee that is the
thing I just need I just need a yes or
no should I do this like I feel like I'm
on the fence here it's like
um you should go do that that that's a
thing you should do now another person
who is trending here is David Hogg do
you remember David Hogg he's the the
founder of or one of the founders of
marketing because of Marjorie Taylor
green
I believe that's why he's trending and
the reason I think why is because
Marjorie Taylor green as everyone knows
from our title is getting divorced well
her husband is divorcing her apparently
he's final for divorce which Gabe on the
grounds of it was a broken uh
what was the exact quote he said Oh I
thought I thought it was because he
found out she had she didn't have a full
foot I don't know I don't know I mean
maybe she was having an affair with that
one guy that was in the cell pretending
to be a Gen 6 insurrectionist you know
some have surmised some have surmise
that her visit to betmenster had mush a
mushroom involved
I'm just saying a small a small one but
very well yeah very tiny tiny small
mushroom like it's like you know like
yeah like a toad or a Vienna sausage you
know
what what you don't like you don't like
Vienna sausages no it's not that I don't
like it's oh you're not ruining you're
ruining the idea of uh you know like a
sausage or a hot dog for me you know
just in general huh right so the the
mushroom talk the toe talk is uh that's
not that doesn't I mean you're okay with
that just the yeah yeah okay I got you
but but sorry her husband quoted uh
irretrievably broken marriage
so
irretrievably broken that what do you
think it is what do you actually think I
mean you know we can speculate oh here's
the thing so well I can tell you right
now like well I don't know exactly what
it is but let's look at the Timeline
right so she had she's had uh multiple
affairs with multiple men over the years
we we know that based on accounts of
people but I thought I thought they were
like in an open marriage I thought that
was a Dr is this or is this actual
adulterior no I don't know about an open
marriage okay okay but people that they
knew like for example you know she'd be
at a pool party and she was you know she
was uh laying out and hanging out and
being with the the tantric sex guru
right but then like oh later is that the
guy with the beard and the weird like
the wrestling shorts yeah exactly that's
that yeah okay that guy is Craig Ivey I
think is his full name okay and then uh
you've got the other guy uh Justin touay
Trey uh I forget if the last name but
this happened back in 2012 2013 okay oh
so this has been a while ago so they've
been a while those at least those two
right right so then you've got the owner
of the gym his account is like oh uh
these are and again this is coming
straight from these people wait wait is
this another one this is another one no
no this is so there's there's the two
guys right there this is straight from
their mouths they have confirmed that
they had an affair all right when the
they admitted to having sex with her
when the daily okay well on The Daily
Mail article came out last year in
February of 2021. these two uh one guy
was like I don't want to talk about it
the other guy was like dude I don't want
anything to do with her anymore
everything bad comes from her
the owner and other people at the gym
that she worked at the CrossFit gym
confirmed these things as well as these
two guys
and the the owner was like oh yeah I
witnessed these things she was very
flirtatious one guy was more of a
serious affair with this other guy you
know it was it was more flirtatious with
Craig Ivey the tantric sex guru guy okay
then there was the other guy Justin
which was like oh this guy it's more of
a like a serious kind of thing he's
looking for are you gonna do a what was
that on this is that what you're
researching I don't know or can you
stomach the thought of talking about how
Marjorie Taylor green has had said I
mean I could bring it up and I can bring
up all the hypocrisy of her trying to
control what women want to do with their
bodies how people should live their
lives right the family values well
that's where this Pride that's where
this privacy is coming into focus with
David Hawk right right right and well
well I don't know what he said yet but I
know that she was like I wanna I would
like everyone to respect our privacy
because this is not your this is not
your business oh tough [ __ ] you kind of
made it everyone's business right you
don't like privacy so [ __ ] yourself
that's the way I feel
that is why and now so you have to ask
yourself was it those two Affairs that
we know of or was it the other Affairs
that other people have confirmed or
given as like oh I was yes I was a
person who was a spectator to that and
she was clearly sleeping around it was
an openly cheating
that happened 10 years ago and from what
I understand they had considered divorce
back then but didn't do it so I don't
know what happened in the last 10 years
if this guy was just like sitting with
it the whole time didn't want to give up
or you know uh or or the you know the
business connection they have together
because again she's not actually she
works for her husband's construction
company which has benefited greatly on
subsidized government
um wait wait wait I I thought that was
her company I thought that was her
family's company or is it their
husband's family's company it's it's
under her husband's name but she doesn't
she doesn't do anything at the cup I see
well she's just there as a as a as a
name on the line but isn't that the
isn't that one of the the places where
it's got the wood paneling behind it in
that where she's broadcasting from is it
or is that I was at the gym because I
thought she was the owner of the gym and
that she owned the gym there with this
guy and that's why I'm confused as [ __ ]
confused she didn't own that gym with a
guy that was a different guy and the
reason the guy is so open he's like oh I
didn't hire her she was inherited in the
acquisition of this of this gym so she
was an employee there that I got when I
bought it and that is why she stuck
around and that's why this guy's like oh
yeah I saw this stuff go down like this
guy was like oh I gotta go spend time
with Marjorie I'm with this I'm I'm
outwardly flirting with this you know
it's so let me ask you do you think do
you think Marjorie Taylor green
can pretend to be young enough to um to
attract Matt gatz because they were
really close for a while so that's
another thing right they spent a lot of
time I mean I've certainly made jokes
about it all the times they've you know
they've I mean I'm doing it right now so
yeah I mean all the times they were in
those hotel rooms together they were
they were traveling in that you know
that uh that broke America first
movement campaign yeah the Nazi the Nazi
rallies that they couldn't raise money
for anymore yeah exactly
um which sounds pretty similar to
Trump's campaign right now he barely he
made forty dollars oh yeah you know we
missed that we missed that we need to
talk about that today too forty dollars
uh in the month of August he made zero
dollars at the Super PAC in the month of
June in July they got a bump up but
right now while the while the uh the
hurricane is going through Florida he
released a video yesterday be like I
need you guys would have an important
fundraising deadline the only important
fundraising deadline is because
September 30th is around the corner and
that's the the end of Q3 so needing to
show that the numbers are better so he's
trying to beg for money so that
September looks better than August which
was forty dollars can you pull that
video up can you do you have that video
is it on your profile yes or where okay
well keep keep going keep talking there
I'll find I'll find it on your profile
so unless you guys no I don't have an
address but basically I'll go video he's
talking about how there's an important
deadline that comes up which is
September 30th right and on the website
when you click the link because I got a
text message on my burner phone that was
like hey uh you got you got a burner
phone yeah I'm just kidding I know yeah
and I'll read it right now the actual
statement that I got in the text message
that was grab your popcorn in Maga had
pres Trump's new video is out now we're
giving you the first chance to view it
and then you click a link and it of
course takes it to a donation page
that's like a hundred dollars already
pre-selected 250 is shaking so that you
click it the recurring donation is
already pre-checked for you the thing
that got them in trouble that they had
their refund over 135 million you mean
the biggest fraud ever in the history of
the country right so you go there and
then on there there's a video and that
video is the one you're about to play
well and I hate to jump around from the
merger day they're green but here's the
thing
is
how many times you think Marjorie Taylor
green is has tried to to Bone Trump I'm
just saying she was really she was
really touchy with him on that cardboard
cutout you'll remember that very gropey
very gropey with the cardboard cutout
which is very weird I wouldn't be
surprised if she certainly made
her advances on him whether it was at
Bedminster you know it was at it maybe
was at a certain I don't know golf
tournament
uh oh because she did appear now you
know what's funny about that because she
was there with uh the Cheeto dust
monster Grandpa Poopypants here and
Tucker Carlson Yeah Yeah Yeah from White
Privilege tonight on Fox News
um he he was there as well so do you
think
I'm I mean I'm these people all claim to
be Christian but they seem to do the
opposite thing uh from Christianity are
these the uh sex parties and orgies that
Madison talked about but I wouldn't be
surprised if those finger prints are on
those papers those could be could be so
let's watch
um the the grandpa poopy oh this is a
good that's a good uh single [ __ ] look
at that pause
oh
looks like he's lining up for a kiss for
hoof foot green okay let's let's play
where he's begging his ass off for money
because he's [ __ ] broke we have a
major fundraising deadline coming up and
there's never been a time like this our
country has never been so disrespected
our country has never been so low
certainly in the minds of others and
especially the leaders of other
countries
did you catch any of that did you get
what any of that said Yeah Yeah so
basically what he's saying is he says
look we gotta raise this money we're not
in great shape other countries don't
respect us or don't think highly of us
now I've got I'm working on a what was
that just for this video
because this [ __ ] is so dumb let's point
out is this the whole video is this the
whole video there's it's like 40 some 40
no no I'm saying I'm saying is it is it
just the 44 seconds oh yeah yeah yeah
you're doing a whole what was that on
this 44 seconds yeah yeah Jesus there
must be there must be a lot of [ __ ]
behind the scenes you're going on you
know some of the things I've mentioned
so far are some of the things I dig into
uh you mean the forty dollars a month
thing forty dollars a month I talk about
also how in 2005 Donald Trump at the
same time there was a there was a
hurricane coming through he made a
fraudulent 17 million dollar claim for
damages and people in Mar-A-Lago were
like there's no damage at all so I'm I'm
connecting these dots of you know this
guy trying to grip for money while
people like Floridians on the other side
of the state are actually suffering in
in losing their property and this guy is
from the luxury of his Mar-A-Lago Resort
making a video saying guys well it's
it's a classified document uh skiff is
where he's at this is a stack that seeds
yeah yeah it just happens to be the same
skiff that all the other people were
just like wandering in and out right but
I do I do want to point out something
else he's got this mini little podium in
the back right here right here and it's
[ __ ] weird isn't it this is the first
time I've seen this thing well he said
he had the mini desk you remember the
little bitty mini desk that he had that
he would sit do you think he wanted a
matching a matching Podium or something
I don't know if that's possibly but you
have to remember that if this is okay so
these are the photos on the wall this is
his office at Mar-A-Lago this is right
this is where he takes pictures he's
taking pictures of like Kyle
writtenhouse Lauren bobert right here
now in a different little different
position because I think if you look if
it's here yeah yeah but up here is like
the picture of the Kim Jong-un right
exactly right okay and this table that
the little miniature podium's on below
that is the Eleven Hundred Dollar
miniature replica of Mount Rushmore with
Donald Trump's face that uh Governor
Christie Noam gave him as a gift wait
wait wait it has it's it's a motto of
Mount Rushmore with his [ __ ] face on
it it's got four faces plus his he's at
the end
and then and then he I don't know and
then he's got this little miniature
Podium all all the projection in this
one little video what a [ __ ] fool
I can't understand how these people are
fooled by him still I just don't get it
let why you're finding it let me let me
finish playing this because I mean
literally we're 17 seconds into this
great 44 second clip
um which you're gonna do you know at
least a half an hour on what was that
about this 44 seconds because I'm sure
there's just Treasure troves of crimes
and grifting that this idiot has done
let's listen all over the world we have
to change it we have to bring our
country back we made America great and
now we're going to have to make America
great again
so I say what you can do help out we
have to meet the deadline the midterms
are coming up it's going to be one of
the most important elections in the
history of our country so I hope you can
help up and help out we really
appreciate it and good luck we have
okay so there's a few things to break
down here one he says that we already
made America great
so we need to make America great again
which was already the campaign slogan
that he had before now what I was hoping
he would do is he would said we already
make America great again now we need to
make America great again again which
he's already said and he even said
directly to people in October of 2020
I'm gonna throw another again after the
again so you guys buy another hat and I
make money off you and everyone's like
right
yay you're gonna grift us but the other
part of this is that he says we've got a
very important deadline the midterms are
coming up
this Super PAC is not paying for the
midterm candidates running in the
midterm or the candidates that are
running in the midterms well that's one
that's one confusion point about super
Pacs super Pacs cannot directly give to
a candidate now they can they can given
support meaning like they can buy ads in
support of that person or really more
more appropriately in our politics by
ads and against their opponent that's
generally how Super PAC show their
support right but what's happening is
this Super PAC for people who are you
know kind of been living under rock or
don't know anything about it uh this
Super PAC is what's paying off his
expenses specifically his legal bills
right so the three million dollars that
went to that new lawyer in Florida
that check cleared and went from that
Super PAC to him
but but wait a second how does because
the it's 40 40 minus
plus math is not checking out here Gabe
it's just it's just not it doesn't does
not make a lot of sense but he's got
money but that right he's built up a
treasure chest yeah exactly so what's
happening here is his legal problems are
directly influencing the money that he
receives which means that the more legal
problems he have the more uh uh people
are unwilling to donate to this this
Super PAC right so right now as as I
said I got this text message that said
grab your popcorn and mega hat pres
Trump's new videos out now we're giving
you the first chance to view it
okay fine weird way to to pitch me on a
video but in the video
he then says you know we have a deadline
uh nobody respects America because uh
because I stole a bunch of documents and
nobody trusts us anymore
um
if there's any if there's any moment
where somebody's like I don't trust the
um
America or I I don't believe that the
reputation is as strong as it is it's
probably because I don't know the guy
standing in the same room that the
documents were seized by the FBI
is the one like he's the creation of the
problem like if people don't respect our
our reputation or respect what we have
as a country it's probably because
somebody I don't know violated the
Espionage Act
but you know the guys
what do you know what do you know yeah
speaking of standing and saying here's
the picture that I was unaware of this
is
um him standing in front of the table
just talking and here uh here up here is
that picture of Kim Jong-un that we were
talking about now the camera was in a
different position for the video
obviously but I don't see the podium on
the table here I think it's like it's a
new addition right and I've and I've
looked through other photos and I can't
find any that specifically that Podium
so I don't know if it's new or he's
redecorating or what have you but this
is the same position in the because
here's the thing this is one this is the
left side I guess you know if you're
looking at the desk this is the left
side of the room then you shift over and
uh if you were to go 90 degrees to the
right on this photo you would see where
his desk is there's a photo of him with
Stephen Miller and I can actually pull
that up and that would give you kind of
perspective in the layout of this room
but because this is the same room that
the FBI took the notorious picture now
of all the documents on the floor where
they laid them because we see the carpet
there but you pointed out to me because
I didn't I I didn't know this I had no
idea
um that Christy gnome had given Donald
Trump if he looked down here there's
this stuff first at first there were
these rumors of like oh look uh this is
Donald Trump right here right yeah yeah
on this thing
so she had this made for him I wonder oh
my God I'm not even gonna go there but
it just this is oh man
I can't I can't do you have a picture of
the the Stephen Miller desk because I
really want to get back to Marjorie
Taylor green
um adultery here yeah I mean if we can
jump back in a moment so if you look at
this photo
ah let me pull this up here let's make
sure we got the right one
okay yeah here okay so this is this if
you go 90 degrees right so where those
curtains were that's what is to the left
of Stephen Miller
this is where his desk is so I don't
know where you know this is the desk
that had the documents in it but the
carpet looks different in this picture
yes so the carpet in this photo looks
different now this is before the carpet
changed oh wait wait a second wait is
wait just a [ __ ] minute are you
telling me
are you telling me that that tacky ass
carpet that he now has in his office he
chose to put in there recently yeah
that's a recent that is a recent change
and one that happened when uh here
here's a Jester here's here's ridiculous
you know the one thing I did notice
about the video is he's not wearing a
tie
he's not wearing the tie in the video
right which is kind of unusual that he's
not wearing a tie I don't know if that
means anything I'm just saying that
right you know I don't know the other
thing about this photo is it looks like
if you notice the the the newspaper here
it looks like it's covering up something
do you think he's covering up top secret
documents that are laying there on the
desk that he didn't want I think he's
covering up like uh fast food like
McDonald's
oh okay so if you look at uh the next
photo I showed you I sent you okay all
right let's see this last one here this
is the same office right so keep in mind
where that corner is look at the corner
right back there that's right this is
where the this is the back here is where
is just where Steve kind of by the where
the desk would right this this table
here now if you look at the carpet
the carpet has been updated throughout
Mar-A-Lago in different areas and this
is one of the rooms his office that has
the updated carpet so this is from the
same photo that was showing the Mount
Rushmore miniature a little statue or uh
right
and this is the carpet updated so that
is why that's why when you see all the
photos of all the thumbs up with Kyle
Rittenhouse and and uh and Lauren bobert
and all these other people they have the
new updated carpet and that's so so you
know and I know this seems trivial
but literally I bet in this documents
case there is probably going to be
something about the carpet I almost bet
because like it is a main I mean
obviously when the FBI lays out the
classified documents out of the box that
it was in stuck between the pictures and
they're like yeah here's the class fight
and they take the evidence photo right
um it shows the carpet I'm sure I'm sure
there's going to be more photos of
people being in this room where the
classified documents were and they
literally are going to be using the
carpet as kind of a date Setter right
like when this was taken here you can
see the carpet I almost bet that's
what's gonna happen uh in some of this
case so let me do this let me get back
to Marjorie Taylor green because I'm
done talking about her boyfriend here oh
excuse me her I guess the cardboard
cutout right now the cardboard cutout is
the boyfriend yeah do you think do you
think do you think Donald Trump I don't
know I don't know if that cardboard
cutoff gave consent
I well I mean you know you gotta grab
them by the cardboard I guess I don't
know but but do you think
um do you think Donald Trump would
actually
have that
do those things with
her do you think I don't know part of me
feels like
uh it's not happening with Melania and
that relationship is not going anywhere
what gives you the sense that that
Melania isn't isn't having sexual
relations with her husband it's just
would it be that hand slapping all
through the presidency to get the hell
away from me type looks and yeah uh
maybe could have been okay or the fact
that she doesn't even want to be in the
same room as him and and lives on the
other side of right there and her
bedroom is more secure than where the
from him than where the goddamn
classified documents I think he's in a
position where he would take whatever he
can get you know he believes that he
could have whatever he wants however
that's not actually the case you would
have to pay someone and I don't think
that's happening because it doesn't have
a lot of money right now and things are
kind of tight so it really comes down to
if someone is offering to him and he
goes so you think he so you think he's
possibly having sex with marjor Taylor
green because he's [ __ ] broke is that
what you're saying who knows that's what
I hear
Taylor green because those are two
different things yeah well I mean
they're kind of can be the same I mean
if you're a broken person you may you
may just engage all I'm saying is that
uh I'm sure
it wouldn't be surprising if Marjorie
Taylor green
offered
to say hey I want to be with you in some
way now the the Striking thing about the
Margaret David green thing to me is
where she's asking for privacy which
isn't you know it's not really unusual
that uh a public figure would say hey
I'm going to divorce please give me
privacy it's just kind of funny coming
from her someone who would cost
teenagers in DC
um about their experience in a [ __ ]
violent school shooting where their
friends were murdered by one of their
classmates right um because Republicans
refuse to do anything about about gun
violence at all but it's also kind of
strange because she absolutely 100 does
not want a woman to have privacy in
their doctor's office which is yeah
really weird that she's worried about
you know her husband's divorce and
because it has to do with adultery and
sex which is you know I don't know if
you've looked at the Ten Commandments
but the Ten Commandments there's one of
them on there actually there's a couple
on there let's talk about directly about
this right right they talk about this
kind of stuff but you know let's let's
slay the Christian nationalism that she
claims to be a Christian nationalist
aside that's a whole another probably 30
minutes right
but it does seem kind of weird that she
does not want any other any other woman
in the country to have privacy when
they're talking about their issues
inside a doctor's office but she
definitely for herself
for herself she wants privacy now right
you know like you gotta defund the FBI
so nobody finds out that I was
potentially doing these things in
Trump's office with the classified
documents right but it's what were they
doing on top of the classified documents
I don't oh okay I thought you were
digging up research on this what was
that and that's all right I just okay
but but what I will add to it is that uh
it's not only women's bodies that she
wants to dictate to say like you can or
can't do this but it's also people in
relationships right those from the lgbtq
community or trans okay whatever the
situation is with that person she wants
to be the deciding
factor to say you have to be male you
have to be female you can't be with each
other you don't have the same rights as
me a woman married to a man does
she wants all of those things to be
stripped away from those people
and she has the the audacity and the
goal to then say uh you know what you
guys should give me my privacy right now
like yeah this is obviously uh an awful
moment in anyone's life to get a divorce
right especially after being married for
27 years did she
directly contribute to the divorce and
that it was uh and that it was broken
probably through her Affairs that she
had could have been for other things she
did I don't know what was the straw that
broke the camel's back in this
relationship because
it's been 10 years or so that we know
that she's had these Affairs you think
it's a q Anon stuff
I don't know I mean let's listen listen
I'll tell you I'll yeah but I'll tell
you something I'll tell you something
and you know that there's Q Anon stuff
boy it really puts stress on
relationships
um you know I you know marriages uh you
know the relationships you have with
your friends your family your brothers
your sisters your mom's your dads I know
I have I have family members personally
that have fallen to this Q Anon stuff
from Facebook and stuff and it
absolutely strains a relationship when a
person can't even be Tethered to simple
reality because then you can't even talk
to him really about anything else and
maybe that's maybe that's part of it is
she's gone down this Q Anon hole so far
that he's just like I it's you know I
forget the quote what did he call it
it's just uh
um broken something improvably broken
there and you know most relationships
where people have bought this Q in line
Q Anon [ __ ] irretrievably broken is a
good description because they're
irretrievable like you can't reel them
in right and the only and the only way
that I would I could see that as the uh
the option which I think is a very
likely uh go here I mean like she's
anti-semitic you know that's that's a
whole thing
primarily through these Q Anon
conspiracies
um yeah but it could be likely that he
holds a lot of these same personal
beliefs but there's a straw that you
draw with this Q Anon stuff where you're
coming up with all this crazy ass [ __ ]
and and the other thing too is she's got
a lot of it seems a lot of legal
criminal liability with January 6 and
her participation in that so maybe maybe
he knows some things that we don't know
and he's preparing like I want to
distance myself from this crazy [ __ ] it
totally I don't know yeah and I mean the
other thing too is like it's it's one of
those things where when she started
running like anyone who runs as a
candidate it's always looked as it is
taboo to be like oh you're not married
you don't have a family how can you run
at this you know your District or your
country whatever it is right like
somebody is is who it does not have a
partner or a you know a a husband or a
wife or whatever looks to be like oh
that person's unstable they don't have
stability in their life we can't trust
them they don't have kids they don't
know how to run this thing so on and so
forth so it very well could be that you
know things are already teetering when
she started running and they're like
look
shit's on the Rocks you gotta stay
together for the image that is you as a
candidate and then now he's come to a
point where he's like yeah [ __ ] this
[ __ ] man this is [ __ ] crazy you're in
you're in right [ __ ] ton of legal
trouble I don't want anything to do with
you the business I need to separate the
business from you
because well that's that's a tough thing
to do in some states and I don't know
their situation like prenuptial but
they've been married for like 27 years
right um you know so this has been a
long marriage so more than likely a lot
of that is all marital assets right that
they're gonna fight over here yeah um
but you know at the end of the day
I almost bet that a lot of this
relationship strain is the Q Anon stuff
and what criminal liability that the Q
Anon stuff has played before her for
believing this nonsense is election
denial and trying to overthrow the
government and using your seat in
Congress to overthrow the government it
just really is a bunch of ridiculous
nonsense and I can't imagine that the
press that she gets or for her Q Anon
believes is any better on and easier on
her and her family speaking of Q Anon
we had Jim stewartson on he surmised
that this guy Michael Flynn you know
General Michael Flynn is you remember
this game yeah this [ __ ] traitor yeah
it's [ __ ] traitor um this guy this
guy
is still out walking among us talking
this is really you know I'm all for the
justice department taking their time
here but you should hear the [ __ ] that
this guy is saying in the microphones to
a bunch of people who are willing to do
almost anything for their Q Anon leader
it is [ __ ] and man it's weird this
[ __ ] that he says here in this video and
I believe Ron is the one who surfaced
this and uh Mike Lynn is uh trending for
it right now
but he's talking about Governors
declaring war Gabe that's what he's
talking about here it's it's some
Bonkers ass [ __ ] because none of it's
actually Tethered to any kind of reality
let me explain it but let's listen to it
here it's only 28 seconds long let's
listen to Trader Mike Flynn
talk about how he's gonna declare war
with Governors I don't know the
Departments of whatever
[Applause]
you know
States states rights
did you know that a governor can declare
war
governor no no they can't
snap we're gonna probably we're gonna
probably see that
so what no no no we're not okay so he's
saying State trades he just says that
like that's the sentence States rats I
don't you know this is more of this
Civil War talk because anyone anyone who
knows anything about people in the South
who are racist pieces of [ __ ] who want
to who who want to act like the Civil
War wasn't about slavery it was about
States rats they say that [ __ ] all the
time like yeah the states rights to let
their citizens own [ __ ] people like
that's slavery that's what it's about
dummy
um here he's talking about this and this
is literally I don't know
if anyone else sees this this way but I
see it as he's literally calling for
civil war because he's saying the
governor has a right to declare war
which a governor does not have the right
to declare war I mean they can they can
make acts of war against
the federal government I guess I mean if
they would choose to but here's what's
really funny about this
and it really
it really hurts my brain to even try to
put this in perspective for people
because they really quite don't
understand that the reddest of the red
Estates
rely the most on federal funding yeah
and what would happen if a governor of
that state said I'm going if he just and
I don't know like a like the Michael
Scott I declare bankruptcy or this is
like a trump mind control thing where
they just thinking and a Beth but if
they declared war on the federal
government like real actual War right
he's talking about violent War
not only
is the army
the soldiers that the governor hands
control over the um National Guard which
is part of DOD not only that
they would cut all federal funding
to that state that's why no one secedes
from the union is because you wouldn't
get federal dollars and and there would
be a mass Exodus from your state you
people really don't grasp how government
and how inter integral our actual
Society is with each other you have no
[ __ ] clue you literally believe that
Los Angeles California Chicago all these
blue liberal cities have nothing to do
with us out here in Rural America they
absolutely do yeah and you have no
[ __ ] clue on how it works and when my
friend says this type of [ __ ] I know
what he's doing
he's trying to protect himself by
stoking violence because I believe Mike
Flynn believes that if he can get Donald
Trump back in power he will get my he
will get Donald Trump to Pardon him
again right
that's what he believes so he's trying
to stoke violence Stoke this idea that
they're gonna have some kind of war and
it's gonna bring King Trump back to the
United States and that they're gonna
just take over and I just it's it's all
a bunch of answers I mean all of those
people are like uh we want yeah we want
us to see fine if you want to break away
from the United States good luck in
supporting yourself I mean if you look
at California and the GDP that we have
also I mean like just look at all the
federal taxes that people pay
every year right uh when you're when
you're filing your taxes you're like
hell this is the federal money that I
owe to the government and then the
government says hey look so we have this
big pot of money that's used for the
federal like you know United States that
we have here and the ones who receive
that money are even the ones who
contribute the least amount right who
have the least amount to offer
um through their states because they
don't produce certain Commodities they
don't have a lot of uh labor or
production coming out of them
it's almost like there's a socialist way
to pay into it and then you get the
benefits much like Ron DeSantis willing
to accept money from the federal
government for aid but unwilling to
support the aid that goes to other
states the same thing was true in Texas
with with uh Ted Cruz right he is
willing to be critical of you know New
Jersey getting aid from federal funding
but as soon as Houston Houston money
were very desperate and it's like you
can't have it both ways you either don't
want government Aid and you don't want a
big government to help out when these
when these uh very
uh you know these natural disasters
these these um happen in the United
States and cause damage and victims and
and what have you Gabe I I don't mean to
stop you yeah but um I have some
breaking Tony Michaels podcast news we
are right now we are at
999 subscribers and I know the front
door I'm dead serious 9
999 subscribers there's gotta be someone
somewhere on YouTube there has to be
someone someone somewhere that is
listening
that had that is going to be the 10 000
subscriber right now on the eternity
this is going to be a story because our
channel is going to blow up I bet one of
these days games we have two three
million subscribers no no question we do
a good enough show this show is the best
[ __ ] showing politics anywhere that
you can find doubt me just show you send
me a [ __ ] link of a show that's
better than this one that does it every
[ __ ] day two hours a day and and
trust me the more subscribers we get the
more support we get we're gonna be doing
three we may be doing eight hours a day
I don't know I have no idea I'm just
saying we're at 9999.
we oh my God 10 032. 10 032 are you
kidding me that's all I gotta say
okay everyone everyone right now
everyone right now that is listening
that has the ability to go over to
YouTube
and And subscribe even though we've we
pushed over ten thousand do it right now
right now as we speak go over to YouTube
and subscribe help create an account if
you ain't got one to subscribe create an
account to subscribe on YouTube you are
the best audience ever I cannot believe
and I didn't mean to cut the
conversation off but this this this
means so much I thought you were just
gonna say ten thousand we hit ten
thousand and then not only that but we
got a 30 we got 33 additional people
than we needed to hit the ten thousand
marks because well now we're at ten
thousand forty six you guys you guys are
the best audience you guys are the best
audience and and I I really it means a
lot to us it really does mean a lot to
us that you guys have pushed us over
this last couple days of ten thousand I
know Midas Touch uh sent out uh
something on YouTube on their Community
page
um you guys mean so much to us we we
wouldn't do this two hours a day if it
weren't for you guys here every single
day and there's more and more of you
every single every single day a it's
just the audience gets bigger and bigger
there's more downloads
um you guys
we had that we had the seven day uh
suspension you guys stuck with this you
said [ __ ] YouTube for that seven days
and you went somewhere else to find the
show
um we are you are the best audience ever
you really are and and I tell you our
moderators in the YouTube chat as well I
want to thank them
um and I know MJ she's in Florida right
now she's safe I was worried about her
and we we have a chat room that we
talked to the moderators and I was
really worried about NJ but she's safe
and she's been in the chat today so
um everyone make sure to tell MJ to stay
stay safe for us we we want her to stay
safe but I want to point out that Robin
and Margie also in the moderators uh we
love you guys you guys do such a great
job
um and you guys uh days that one of them
can't be here the other one's here to
help moderate people in the chat uh and
you guys love the chat it's cathartic
for you guys guys I know that sometimes
it's hard for us to keep up with the
chat there's so much engagement uh just
on Facebook on YouTube on Twitch you
guys are the best audience ever and
thank you so much for ten thousand it
really means a lot to us it does more
than you know
um it means a lot and and we're on the
road to a hundred thousand really a
million because I believe I believe we
can have several million subscribers
here on the Tony Michaels podcast we can
have hundreds of thousands of people
watch every single day
um I know I know sometimes it's a
challenge with only two hours a day I
don't understand how other shows do it
like 30 minutes a week
like you you have found you this what
was that that you've been doing like
you're like Jesus Christ like as soon as
you cut it and you're done and you're
like here's another with this Jeremy
thing right you did one on him and boom
here's another [ __ ] thing that you
could have thrown in there if you just
waited yeah exactly it's crazy there's
so much [ __ ] I wish I would have known
that you know release it and I was
talking with Fred yesterday about it and
I was like
you know oh it turns out that it was
potentially the DUI that it got caught
for that right the demotion he was never
promoted so you know it is one of those
things where it's like yes uh if I could
have a like oh here's an update here's
an update here's an update I would
totally do that but like
it's hard keeping up with all the news
like just doing if someone were to do 30
minutes a week on something it would be
like okay we have 30 seconds for you to
cover each of these bits right straight
we would they wouldn't get they wouldn't
get through any news and we missed so
much like we missed the forty dollars uh
in one month we couldn't get to it
because there's so much stuff and we
really do run off your support you great
people out there that listen to us we
run off your support whether you're
subscribing to the channel whether
you're following us on Twitter you're
voting on The bonehead of the week poll
which we have coming out today
um just coming here and watching every
single weekday for two full hours you
guys watch this thing the entire time
the whole two hours and and I'm not
surprised because it's it's such a great
way to come and watch and be cathartic
about politics but really lean into your
democracy and we do run on your support
and if you want to give support
whether you're subscribing liking
sharing that means so much to us and
coming here and chatting every day
that's what we love the most like we
love the most that you guys are here
engaging but if you'd like to support us
monetarily that is great too we take
tips you can go to Tony Michaels dot
live slash tip Tony Michaels dot live
slash tip or just go to
tonymichaels.live and it's there on the
homepage as well yeah but you can give a
one-time tip you can give a monthly tip
because we run off your support this is
how we do it this is how we stay here
every two every day for two hours this
is how Gabe does this what was that this
is how we stay with you in front of you
so you guys can listen and engage with
us and we appreciate every single one of
you we really do another way you can is
to go to store.the20michaels.com
and you can get your favorite dark
Brandon uh design or or you can get your
um your your [ __ ] Rhonda Santos can go
[ __ ] himself there's that one there too
so
um but again it means so much to us that
that uh we got to 10 000 today
um and we should even uh make a graphic
or something
um to thank these folks and post it out
there on social media because we really
we really do appreciate every single one
of you that comes here every single day
so and we're gonna run out of time so
but let's get back to the shitless round
another sappy [ __ ] yeah none of this
[ __ ] thank you thank you but that's
enough you're right that's enough of
that I want to show this because you
brought up uh to state of California we
were talking about
these secession succeeding and Texas is
always a state that you know kind of
talks about this all the time it's it's
just an ongoing thing Gavin Newsom the
governor of California was actually in
Texas and he did an interview on MSNBC
uh with Alex Witt here here is here is
part of that here's about a minute of it
and what he says the way he delivers
this here man this guy this guy I don't
know if he's gonna be president one of
these days but he certainly has The
Knack for the messaging and he certainly
has a way about him that I think um he's
definitely at this point he's qualified
to run for president if nothing else
let's listen but we have a messaging
problem I really believe it and you can
argue what are we doing on conference of
immigration reform what are we doing in
a number of other issues I'm not going
to deny
substantive challenges our party has as
well addressing those tough and vexing
issues it's not just a messaging problem
but a messaging problem that has
persisted with our party for years and
years constantly on the defense we allow
these culture wars to take shape and we
consist in there on the back end of them
eight of the top 10 states with the
highest murder rates all are Republican
states
how do Democrats not know that in fact
it's really nine out of 10 Georgia went
for Biden but it's really a Republican
state at least a red State eight out of
ten and we're losing that message
crime is higher as well as taxes here
for the average uh citizen in Texas it's
higher crime higher violent crime and
poverty crimes than in the state of
California 67 percent higher gun death
rate in Texas why don't wheat push back
why aren't we why why don't we I don't
know
and that's where I was just saying we do
push back here on the Tony Michaels
podcast I do not give a [ __ ] we will
politicize every point I was on Ron
DeSantis yesterday as the storms bearing
down on Florida and I will continue to
be on Ron DeSantis [ __ ] him he can go
[ __ ] himself because the guy that this
this nonsense about oh we need to
succeed in all this [ __ ] and we
don't want we don't want to be part of
the federal government you [ __ ] line
sex as [ __ ] because Ronda Santos is
going to be begging begging for federal
assistance gonna be oh thank you so much
for the bema and blah blah he'll go on
and on but the [ __ ] voted
voted to not give aid for Hurricane
Sandy because their Coastal Elites or
it's a blue Air whatever there's [ __ ]
excuseless I mean he was on Tucker
Carlson last night talking about the
same thing yeah that clip do you have
that clip yeah yeah grab that because
because here's the thing that alone gave
that alone a congressman voting against
giving federal aid for a natural
disaster should automatically with the
voters not legally but automatically
with voters should disqualify you from
being a governor absolutely disqualify
you if you are a person a politician who
believes and who has voted to make sure
people do not receive federal natural
disaster relief when there is an event
like this because Governors are the ones
responsible for this you shouldn't be
nowhere near the office of any
governorship in any state if you have
ever voted especially even just say it
but if you have voted in a body that
would grant that relief to those states
to those governors
to make sure they're constituents have a
recovery the easiest and quickest path
they can and get their economy and their
state back on track you the voters that
should be the the biggest disqualifier
right there right there as Governor I
just it's crazy to me
um
so
you got this uh you did you find the
Tucker Carlson clip okay here it is um
so what well obviously with these [ __ ]
what am I going to see in this clip I
mean obviously I'm gonna see two Rubes
yeah yeah so this uh you know this is
from from Aaron and he and he's covering
how Ron DeSantis was on Tucker Carlson's
show and was given this loaded question
about you know receiving federal aid in
the bite Administration and the response
that uh Rhonda Santas had I think is is
very telling you know I'm actually
cautiously optimistic that you know
Biden would be helpful [ __ ] that dude
he's gonna help your state out because
that's what a president does he does he
already deployed FEMA even ahead of time
he doesn't he doesn't say oh you know
what you're a red State uh let me get
give me a moment let me think about it
there was a president there was a
president that did that though I forget
what his name was oh that was the same
president that threw the paper towels
out at uh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
right yeah that's right that's right
that's right and yeah his name is Donald
Trump by the way oh oh that guy got it
got it that's the same guy that knew
that this guy wants to be you take a
paper towel you oh you're surviving a
hurricane you get a paper towel right
it's so really so wow terrible you know
someone's got to throw those paper
towels at at people Somebody's gotta do
it and also okay they're still waiting
for eight
right and they just went through another
natural like of right because we're in
storm season they just went through
another natural disaster of dealing with
this and damage and they're still
waiting don't you think Puerto Rico
should be a state in that in that a good
call I mean like just in that just in
that ditty alone that is enough
justification in Puerto Rico right we
are past this time of it's only 50
states these are our these are our
properties right that we own them
then that's part of our Empire right
they should be included
enough of this second class citizenry
[ __ ] just make a mistake already just
make a mistake already and and get it
done but here's here's uh uh Cocker
Carlson and uh Ron
can go [ __ ] himself to santus and I'm
sure this is just riddled with gross
vile [ __ ] but we don't look away here
let's
see what they have to say
when a natural disaster like this
strikes the state it is it is common
it's I I think it's always the case that
the state receives federal aid given how
politicized things are at the moment are
you confident you're going to get the
federal support Florida needs
so I actually spoke with the president
and he said he wants to be helpful so we
did submit a request for reimbursement
for the next 60 days at 100 percent uh
why why would you do that why why would
you why would you want to waste federal
dollars around DeSantis why would you
want to go ask for welfare why would you
want to ask for a handout when you
didn't earn it why you need to pull
yourself up by the bootstraps buddy now
in this clip you see Tucker Carlson try
to lob a softball at this [ __ ] by
saying oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Joe Biden you know
well let's go Brandon [ __ ] as if Joe
Biden's not gonna give you he's not
going to give you Aid because you're Ron
DeSantis and Rhonda Sands is like
actually I talked to the president
United States so there is a strike
against Ronda Santos with these fascists
anyways because he actually communicated
he got communication with the Demonic
demon that's in the White House this is
this is really ridiculous Brandon right
Brandon said yeah sure of course yeah
why wouldn't I give you money are you
kidding me why wouldn't we reimburse you
100 of course we're going to whatever
you need Ron the way in which Ron
DeSantis is trying to frame this well
he's like well we already submitted the
expenses to be reimbursed 100 like
everyone didn't already [ __ ] know
there was a hurricane ravaging through
your state like do you think the
government's like oh look a little light
storm is happening yeah whatever and
turn the other way no he's going to I
don't know practice actual Christian
values or just be an empathetic human
and say oh [ __ ] there's a lot of victims
and there's a lot of damage from
Hurricane Ian we should help out like we
always do and we always should when it
comes to these types of disasters so I
as a president will send FEMA I will
send Aid I will give you all the help
you need and of course why is this even
a discussion I'm going to reimburse you
for all the things that you do to help
your state out that's right here
whatever whatever you need whatever you
need Ron whatever you need yeah it's
whatever you need don't even question it
but also
the way in which he phrases it well I'm
cautiously optimistic I submitted an
expense report so I hope Finance
approves it you know like Jesus why are
we even having this discussion you're
trying to shift it to be like I had a
conversation like because what he's
trying to do right now is he's trying to
frame it so like yes he had a
conversation with Biden and it wasn't
like a oh yeah he's gonna give us
everything we need this was like oh we
had to request it we had to ask for it
and that is why he's trying to navigate
he's like oh I had to go to the present
and I had to make sure that he knew we
had a hurricane down here and he knew
that we were spending money of our own
state to do this so we should get
reimbursed because we're Justified
he's trying to frame it as he's the one
who's doing the work for Floridians
right which we know we know we gotta
watch this [ __ ] on where this
money goes anyways right because of how
he [ __ ] how he allocates funds
allocates resources and directs him
towards people he likes and then uses
them against people he hates let's let's
let's finish this clip up that's uh
significant uh support but it's a
significant storm so we haven't heard
back from it but I'm actually cautiously
optimistic that we do I mean as you say
tucker we live in a very politicized
time but you know when people are
fighting for their lives when their
whole livelihood is at stake when
they've lost everything uh if you can't
put politics aside for that uh then
you're just not going to be able to so
I'll work with anybody who wants to help
the people of Southwest Florida and
throughout our state okay and there he's
queuing up the fact that he knows that
his opponent Charlie Crist was actually
um ousted from the Republican Party
Chris Christie was done the same when
they appeared with Obama after natural
disaster Ronda Santos knows This
Moment's gonna come when Joe Biden or
some of the administration officials are
going to show up in Florida to go okay
what's the ground assessment what can we
do to help what more can we do to assess
what has happened in Florida and he
knows he's going to appear with these
[ __ ] and he's already looking
for an excuse for his [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] vile supporters out there that are
that are that the tail that Wags the
fascist dog these [ __ ] these
Maga Republicans
and that's what he's doing here he's
already cueing it up that oh well I can
work with anyone please don't punish me
please don't punish me for taking help
from Biden because I need it because I
need it to to make sure that I remain
governor and this vile piece of [ __ ] and
you know what you know what I say Gabe
do you know what I say I say I say
Rhonda santis can go [ __ ] himself that's
right
Rhonda Sanders look at that [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
I I we I made that shirt
um because that well that graphic I mean
a graphic because of what he did and how
he treated uh Asylum Seekers the
migrants from from Venezuela escaping a
communist murderous regime there yeah um
and how he treated him like pieces of
meat and his political theater where he
where he [ __ ] trafficked them across
state lines out of a different state
into his State and then to a different
state altogether people should not
forget that just because there's this
hurricane that's coming through Florida
no one should forget the fact that Ron
DeSantis tried to and did
uh traffic innocent humans seek an
asylum to another state to own the libs
right and then he's gonna do the same
thing with this because he's going to do
the same thing with this he's going to
do the same [ __ ] thing folks we're
out of time I want to tell you again
thank you so much for the 10 000
subscribers yeah it means so much to us
it seems it means the world to us make
sure you go subscribe bribe and follow
us on Twitter as well at Tony Michaels
pod today is Thursday so bone in the
week poll comes out today don't miss it
we already know some people that are
going to be on that list yeah I know I
know you know since we're on Facebook go
follow us on Facebook maybe I'll start
putting the bonehead pull over there too
maybe I'll do that maybe I'll now that
we're on now
what are you doing here Tony I'm trying
to say well I know I know this this one
Ryan I know but we all we'll have to
certify the vote from three different
places every single week uh have a
Electoral College maybe and then you
know have Mike Pence uh Crown someone
king
um also go download every single episode
don't forget to do that listen to us
while you're cleaning or in the car or
whatever you're doing run whatever you
know right or whatever you have a primal
scream in the woods somewhere right if
you need that cathartic relief anywhere
you are download on Apple Spotify Google
leave us a great review while you're
subscribing on your favorite directory
for the Tony Michaels podcast everyone
same time same place tomorrow remember
it's Friday so in the second hour
bonehead of the week our favorite
segment until tomorrow same time same
place Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon